we have been so happy to be able to
celebrate the personal joy of our newest
addition with you all eighty-six have
arrived it's a new challenge it's a it's
a new chapter right Megan Markel has
given birth to her first child with
Prince Harry this will be a historic
royal baby it's going to change the line
of succession
Prince Edward will not be knocked out
but can we expect the newest royal to
have a royal title they won't be a
prince or a princess they won't have
that HRH title unless of course the
Queen sets in and gives them that title
which is what she did with the Cambridge
children Kensington Palace announced
that the 37 year old Duchess was
expecting on October 15th the same day
she and Harry touched down in Sydney
Australia for their first official royal
tour we also generally couldn't think of
a better place to announce the upcoming
baby beard a boy or girl and just five
months after their royal wedding it's
likely that Megan would have conceived
probably towards the middle or end of
July that's just two months after they
got married so this is really very very
quick the Duchess has reportedly had a
fairly easy pregnancy unlike
sister-in-law Kate Middleton Megan has
felt very fit and very well throughout
her pregnancy
unlike the Duchess of Cambridge she
hasn't suffered any morning sickness and
her instruction to AIDS has been fill up
my diary until the due date I feel fit
I'm ready to work and she's done just
that in addition to her two-week tour of
Australia New Zealand Tonga and Fiji
Megan joined Harry for a three-day trip
to Morocco in late February just days
before she embarked on a solo journey to
New York for her lavish baby shower and
some quality time with friends the
Duchess also surprised a wedding dress
designer
Claire wait Keller with designer of the
year at the British Fashion Awards
Claire wait Keller is probably the most
important person in Megan's life at the
moment because she is designing a
bespoke maternity wardrobe for Megan
who was showing a very burgeoning bump
last night and she attended a number of
official engagements including paying
visits to her newly named patronage 'as
the national theater the association of
Commonwealth universities the Mayhew
animal home and smart works I think
Prince Harry has tried to encourage her
to slow down a little bit but you know
Megan Megan is a grafter she's a hard
worker and her feeling is that while
she's bitten well she'd like to work up
as close to her due date as possible and
she's got a killer fashion sense no
matter how far along megan has been in
her pregnancy
she's given us major pregnancies style
inspo at every single event now that
baby Sussex is finally here Megan is
expected to take some well-deserved time
off while she adjusts to her new role of
mom I think after that we will see a lot
less of the couple Megan is probably
going to take around six months we think
but already we're hearing whispers of a
tour in the fall to America and Canada
so she really could be back to work as
early as October which would mean a
maternity leave of about six months
although something tells us
Megan won't be able to lay low for quite
that long congratulations to the new
parents
[Applause]